hello and welcome to the markiplier new
home tour here you'll find an assortment
of incredible amenities including
toilets I don't know what backwater
country you come from but here we have
toilets
amazing what a time to be alive
always remember to reverse gyrate your
way out of bathrooms for everyone's
safety here you'll find the master
bedroom filled with nothing I have two
fingers here's the ceiling and there's
some windows delightful also a closet
very good for thumbing up let us journey
over here take a look at the mirror it's
filled with a handsome man ready to
entertain you here's another bathroom
but watch out there's a dark secret
no but stammers gonna get us today
continuing on let's look at that
handsome man again and venture off into
the second bedroom here you have a
lovely lakeshore view of the other
apartments here you have a wall a door a
ceiling or ceiling and that handsome man
again look at him go well let's go say
hi to the handsome man and continue
forward here's the main attraction the
lovely spiral stairs grab on tight you
don't want to fall and die by breaking
your neck in 17 places look at my hand
you have exactly one second to look at
the kitchen
hope you enjoyed the kitchen moving on
and here's the floor lovely for standing
on
and a final view for thumbing up isn't
it just delightful filled to the brim
with potential for creative goodness but
wait there might be more another
lakeshore view of the apartments
delightful and here's an extra bathroom
that no one knows why exists
probably just so that crazed butt
stabber can get you but thanks for
watching bye bye